another violent case involves a school
secretary who was being assaulted by a
student the teen in that case has been
sent to a juvenile detention center
victoria saha joins us live from north
las vegas tonight to give us some
insight on what happened and how
teachers are feeling
yeah there was never anything that was
made public about this incident earlier
this week but a teacher here at legacy
high school came forward exclusively to
eight news now telling us a secretary
was attacked by a student monday morning
a look at the incident report uploaded
to a school portal was given to us by
sources at legacy high school detailing
the attack on the principal's secretary
it says the student was punching her in
the head and choking her we as teachers
are
kind of
done you know like we need to feel safe
and we don't this teacher who asked to
remain anonymous says the monday morning
attack happened right before classes
started
we never heard anything from
admin
her principal
nobody has even spoken to us about any
of it clark county school district
police confirms to us it was a 17 year
old female student involved honestly the
battery against our staff
is very rare but again when it happens
basically it's one of those things it's
just like it strikes us to our core
because you know we're there for the
staff and the students lieutenant brian
zinke says when two school officers were
trying to arrest the student she fought
back the incident report says another
employee also tried to intervene
lieutenant zing says school staff do
have the right to defend themselves you
can only defend yourself to the point
where you're attacking or battering the
other person
that incident report also states that
student sent a threatening email to a
teacher that very same morning that
teacher stayed home in fear of their
safety now this student faces several
charges including battery on a
protective person and damage to school
property reporting live tonight from
north las vegas victoria saha live local
now